par exemple quand nos auteurs ont
travaillé sur euh les pirates du futur
et ont imaginé des villes flottantes
avec plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
vivaient dedans des apatrides et bien
ils se sont tournés vers des experts
pour dire comment est-ce qu'on nourrit
ces villes flottantes euh la première
euh la première version des scénarios
faisait apparaître de la picculture et
en fait en travaillant avec les experts
il s'estavérit que c'est pas du tout
viable pour nourrir plus de 2000 ou 3000
personnes parce que ça ne produit pas
assez donc ils ont été imaginés des bacs
dans lequel des bactéries produisaient
des protéines alors c'est pas très
ragoutûtant je suis désolé pour cette
matinée mais voilà des exemples très
concrets et autre exemple sur
l'ascenseur spatial qui avait été évoqué
sur un des scénarios également bon il
ils ont été chercher des experts en
anneau carbone et également des
économistes c'est important pour savoir
combien coûtait un ascenseur spatial
demain je vous donne le prix c'est 100
milliards de d'euros